-How do you know what to do?
Like, how to protest something
-We didn't.
You know,
we made a ton of mistakes.
We argued with each other.
We weren't
intersectional enough.
We called our meetings pow-wows.
-Oh, no.
-Mm-hmm.
-But you're glad
you did it all, right?
-Of course. What are
you gonna do, nothing?
-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here with Amy Poehler.
The movie's really great,
and one of the things
you absolutely nailed it wit
was this young cast
that's in the film.
-Yeah.
-They're just incredible.
-They're so incredible.
And, you know,
they worked so hard, and I was
able to work them so hard.
I mean, you know, none of them
had kids or anything,
so I would just --
every time they finished,
I would just go, "Again.
Do it again!
Do it better!
Do it faster!
Do it younger!"
[ Laughter ]
And it was so great.
-So maybe a bit of a contras
to your directing
of "Wine Country."
-Yeah, "Wine Country" was like
"Please don't leave, guys.
We only have a few more hours.
Please, focus.
Guys, the set's over there
No, we can't go to dinner yet.
[ Laughter ]
-Um, hey, were you --
This is a movie about a daughter
who finds her mom's old zine
and decides to protest
a certain behavior at school
We both have educators
in our family,
and I think that sometimes
hamstrung being protest-forward.
Were you a rabble-rouser
in school?
-No, I -- You know, people hav
asked me this question a lot
"Were you rebellious
in high school?"
And I sadly was not
really at all.
And I kind of feel like you an
I might share similar stories,
'cause your mom
was a teacher, too.
My mom was a teacher
at my high school.
She was literally
around the corner.
So, I mean, I --
I occasionally, you know,
graffiti'd something,
but it was, like,
school-sponsored rocks tha
we were allowed to spray-paint
[ Laughter ]
You know?
-Um, I want to talk about
one of your friends.
I know you've worked with he
in things like "Parks and Rec.
Kathryn Hahn just had
this incredible moment
in "WandaVision,"
and she's always amazing,
but has your friendship with her
made you think that
you would like to find your wa
into the Marvel Universe?
-Thank you for asking, Seth.
Yes, Kathryn Hahn
is a living legend,
and one of the best actresse
we have around,
and she's incredible.
But I do feel like there's a lot
of room in the Marvel Universe
for people who could
just be, like, the helpers
And I feel like -- I think
I could be Brie Larson's, like
I don't know, bossy sister who's
not in the biz or something,
who's just, like --
[ Both laugh ]
They're like,
"Gretchen, what do you want?
She's like, "I don't know.
What are you guys doing?
You want me to turn on
the lasers?"
Like, I feel like
there could be somebody
who's turning on the lasers.
'Cause you never see that.
You never see who's turnin
things on and off.
-Right.
-Who's closing up
the headquarters at night.
And I feel like --
And I'm so jealous
of all of these mother [bleep]
down in Australia right now --
-Lot of movies
shooting in Australia.
-Everyone's like,
"I'm on the set of 'Thor.'
And it's like, "No,
I'm on the set of 'Thor.'
And it's so nice down here
And we don't even care
about COVID!"
It's like, "Keep it to yourself.
Keep it to yourself."
So, I propose
a small indie Marvel thing
shoots near my house.
And I could play
somebody's sister who is i
charge of turning on the lasers.
That's all I'm saying.
-Gotcha. So just --
Let's say I'm Kevin Feige
at Marvel,
and you're auditioning
for Captain Marvel's
older sister, Karen --
-Gretchen. Not Karen.
-What?
-Come on, Seth. Not Karen.
Wow.
-Sorry, that's how it was
written in the comics,
and we're not gonna change it.
-Well, then that's
gonna be a pass.
Because my agent didn't tell m
her name was Karen!
I thought it was Gretchen.
If it's Karen, no, thank you
Okay?!
And can I talk to the manager?
Because nobody told me
that her name was Karen!
[ Laughter ]
Okay?
My agent didn't tell me,
so I'd like to speak to somebody
about changing her name.
-It's just -- This is Marvel
We don't have a manager.
-Oh, okay. Oh, I'll wait until
I get the Marvel manager.
Thank you so much.
[ Laughter ]
-Okay, so you audition
for Gretchen.
We would love -- So
Captain marvel is going off --
She's going off to fight i
space, and we would just love,
like, what you think an olde
sister would say on her way out?
-"Be careful, Captain Marvel
Be careful.
I mean, don't -- don't --
You don't have to go."
Is that good?
-That was really good.
Do you --
I mean, you wouldn't tell Thor
if they found a part for you
in "Thor,"
you wouldn't go to Australia
-Okay, if they found a par
for me in "Thor," I'd be o
a friggin' plane in 2.2 seconds.
But I want to tell you something
else about Australia.
And, you know, this is something
I could be excited about.
Remember a couple years ago,
the cave rescue?
The boys were -- they lived, and
I talked about it on your show
-Yeah.
-Well, the great Ron Howar
is making a film about it.
Guess who was cast today
as some of the cave rescuers
Are you ready?
-Yes.
-Joel Edgerton.
-Great.
-Colin Farrell.
-Oh!
-Viggo Mortensen.
-Oh, my God.
-And guess where
they're shooting it.
Guess where they're shooting it.
-Australia.
-Yeah.
And guess what I'm playing
-Who?
-The cave.
[ Laughter ]
Fingers crossed.
I don't know.
My agent has a call in.
I'm excited.
-[ Laughing ]
-I'm gonna be like,
"What are you guys doing here?
[ Laughter ]
I'd love to come down
to Australia.
I know what's happening
down there.
-Oh, my God.
So that's so exciting.
So, Mortensen, Farrell,
Edgerton, and you're the cave.
-I knew I was I gonna see that
film because I love that story
but I didn't know I was gonna be
excited about that film.
Like, I didn't know
I was gonna be
in the front row for that film
I mean, those three?
-I mean, that's like --
It's worth getting stuck
in a cave for
if they're gonna show up.
-You know what?
You're right.
And think of how much arguin
is gonna happen
between the three of them.
They're gonna be like,
"We gotta go this way!"
"No, we gotta go this way!
-Oh, yeah.
There's only one thing
they're gonna agree on,
which is, "We gotta get
those kids out of that cave!
[ Laughter ]
-Right.
And one of them is gonna b
like, "Or push them in more!
They're gonna be like,
"Get out of here!
We don't want
to push them in more!"
I don't know.
When I saw that, I was like,
"I want you to know that whe
I read that today, I was like --
This is our relationship.
I was like, "Oh, my God!
I can't wait to tell Seth
on his show
that they cast the cave movie!
-Yeah, I mean,
those are three --
those are three classics for me.
I mean,
that ticks all of the boxes.
-Those guys, come on.
-Yeah.
I mean, it's --
-Think of the --
Think of just the -- Well --
-I bet there's gonna be --
-Now I'm just -- Yeah.
-I think there's gonna be a lo
of, like, that thing
that I know you love.
Guys with, like,
their scuba masks,
but then they have
to put them up here to talk.
-Oh! And their hair
flips out a little bit, and --
[ Laughter ]
And --
You're right!
There's gonna be so much -
There's gonna be so much
scuba mask -- object work.
I mean, this is where --
no offense, Seth, you would --
you'd flounder because
you're not good with props
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-Anyway, I'm so glad
those boys were saved,
and I'm very, very excited
about that casting.
And I think that you shoul
do your show from Australia.
-I think it would be great
Just for, like --
We'll do cave week.
[ Laughter ]
We're going to do it
from inside a cave,
and all of the guests
are gonna have to swim in.
So the only way onto set
is through
a tunnel that's full of water.
-Yeah.
-So only really -- only really
good swimmers can be on.
-You know, like, in those pool
in Florida where you can have,
like, the table in the pool?
You have your cocktail in it
That's where
your desk should be.
[ Laughter ]
And then,
you have people swim in.
That's actually not a bad idea
-Yeah, all right.
So, we'd love to have you
for cave week in Australia
to promote your new film.
-I would absolutely love to be
I'll already have been there
'cause I'm gonna be
working on that movie.
-I love you very much.
Congrats on "Moxie."
Thanks for being here.
-I love you, buddy.
It's great to see you.
I miss you very much.
-Come back to New York soon.
"Moxie" is available
on Netflix now.